DK Mecha might have put us on to the
most unique touchdown celebrations yet
and it involves talking trash without
actually saying a word try sign language
see DK was finding more than $98,000 in
his career for excessive celebrations
and a sportsman like conduct so he's
been learning ASL for a while to get his
mind off of football and to not get fine
when he scored his first TD against the
Cowboys in week 13 he broke out the
standing on business celebration
something that he picked up from
spending time learning ASL and is
getting acknowledgement from his popular
Tik Tok creat in the death and heart of
hearing community and I was I look and I
like oh d d c signed the video and I was
like really and I look and I was like he
did do the video because I haven't seen
anybody do the same sign I sign Sig off
business DK sign language operations are
becoming so popular even his opponents
like 49ers Long Snapper Tabor pepper are
clapping back at DK and sign language
but it's dope that the ASL Community is
getting love from the players even if it
is a talk